le trafic de stupéfiant et ces derniers
temps liés un phénomène qui préoccupe de
plus en plus les autorités un phénomène
très inquiétant de très jeunes tueurs à
gages il y a quelques jours peu de temps
avant d'être arrêté la vidéo d'un jeune
homme de 18 ans soupçonné d'avoir commis
cette assassinats et circuler
massivement sur les réseaux sociaux
des contrats réalisés pour le compte de
véritables mafia qui lui aurait permis
de gagner 200000 euros et comme lui
d'autres jeunes sont eux aussi prêt à
tuer pour être payés on a des très
jeunes personnes qui sont recrutées
parfois sur les réseaux sociaux pour
tuer des cibles qu'on leur désigne tu
auras gâché les jeunes révélations sur
un fléau qui gangrène les cités
merci Alain Bauer un plaisir de vous
avoir à chaque fois sur ce plateau
professeur de criminologie et bien sûr
on va parler vivre au bout de l'enquête
les plus grandes affaires criminelles
passent au crime ça c'est un bonheur ça
c'est un bonheur pour ceux qui comme moi
sont fans
les enquêtes et qui adorent et c'est le
livre de l'émission culte bien sûr avec
Marie Drucker et ça c'est vrai que ça
c'est très très fort merci Alain d'être
là et moi je me régale avoir ses
émissions bien entendu mais c'est vrai
que là on a l'impression que c'est vrai
que on croyait que c'était quand on
regardait ses émissions d'idées voilà on
n'est pas touché c'est fait isolé ça ça
arrivera jamais c'est des légendes de
rien mais là de plus en plus et surtout
de depuis qu'on a vu ce reportage
dimanche on parle de tueur à gages c'est
vrai que c'est quoi un tueur à gages
alors c'est quelqu'un qui est foutu mais
qui n'a aucune raison de vous tuer sauf
l'argent c'est ça voilà il vous connaît
pas il sait pas qui vous êtes il en a
absolument rien à battre mais par contre
si c'est bien payé ou mal payé
d'ailleurs tu ça commence à 50 balles et
ça va jusqu'à 1 million de dollars quand
vous êtes vraiment une personnalité vous
vous êtes dans le niveau au côté prix
c'est bon 50 balles grosso modo c'est
pour la police d'assurance pour se
débarrasser du mari ou de la femme ou de
l'amant ou de la maîtresse mais en ne se
faisant pas prendre et en général dans
80% des cas c'est pour toucher la prime
d'assurance ou l'Héritage quand vous
dites 50 balles c'est 50 000 euros genre
le langage
50 euros quand vous n'avez rien et que
vous êtes à Medellin Kelly ou fin fond
à Marseille vous commencez pour pas très
cher pour le règlement de compte avec
des gens qui viennent
les mecs
tué en tout cas essayez de le tuer car
il se trouve que il y a plus de
tentatives que de réussite ce qui est
une bonne nouvelle pour ceux qui
survivent mais par contre l'augmentation
des tentatives d'homicides pour des
raisons de règlement de compte du trafic
de non-paiement de vol
de stupe et puis par ailleurs c'est pas
les premiers de la classe quoi souvent
ils ont pas un niveau extrêmement
développé notamment à les raconter tout
ça sur les réseaux sociaux n'indique pas
qu'on est dans le professionnel le plus
accompli de l'histoire mais ceci dit il
faut savoir que les plus jeunes chez
lesicario s'ils avaient 13 ans j'en ai
retrouvé un d'ailleurs rawell Raoul
pardon media Torres c'était le plus
jeune tueur de l'histoire c'était lui un
descendant de un Mexicain il y avait
quel âge 13 ans
il s'est fait abattre lui-même par
quelqu'un visiblement d'Agen un peu plus
un peu mieux ou plus efficace en 2010
vous en avez un anglais qui a été arrêté
en 2011 il avait 16 ans 20 ans de tôle
donc le sicaire il était jeune soit
parce que c'est un apprenti qui la
prenait le métier ça fait partie du
dispositif soit parce que il était un
professionnel qui débutait et donc quand
on débute on casse les prix avant d'être
reconnus comme un maître de l'art c'est
très c'est très business tout simple et
plus rarement parce que c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est pour la première fois
on a eu un groupe de tueur à gages qui
ont été arrêtés à Paris 6 et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'avait pas vu
depuis les années 30 où il y avait eu
une entreprise appelée murd incorporaton
sa du meurtre qui était une entreprise
criminelle de jeunes gens de 15 à 25 ans
qui s'était mis à disposition des
groupes et des gangs pour tuer
ce qu'il ne connaissait pas pour ne pas
se faire prendre il faisait en fait du
prêt du prêt d'assassin
jamais prendre bah tous ceux qu'on
connaît pas ceux qui vont pas sur les
réseaux en général et les autres se font
beaucoup arrêter mais peu condamnés car
en général on est seul et donc comme il
y a aucun lien aucune relation et quand
on a un professionnel on fait sa
proprement on se fait pas prendre la
signature par contre et plus
intéressante c'est qu'on peut remonter
une pratique criminelle en fonction de
l'art utilisé de la méthode utilisée le
sicario ça vient de la Sica la CICA
c'est un poignard recourbé et comme on
pouvait le cacher et que c'était très
efficace c'est devenu le sicker
en Israël en Palestine et puis le
sicario ce qu'est devenu la le nom
général donné au tueur à gage où tu
auras forcé comme on dit souvent vous
avez parlé deux fois un des réseaux
sociaux parce que dans l'émission des
équipes de TF1 ils ont fait un
réalisateur dans la un reportage dans la
cité de la paternelle qui se trouve dans
les quartiers nord de Marseille et on a
fait la connaissance de d'un suspect qui
s'appelle Mathéo il a 18 ans et il s'est
vanté sur télégram de ses actes regardez
ça va tout baiser sur la vie de ma mère
qui va te jurer mon sang sur la zone tu
vas péter un plomb
voilà alors donc Matteo il a quel âge il
a 18 ans et donc c'est vrai que
maintenant aussi on envoie sur les
réseaux sociaux qui disent voilà
il y a beaucoup beaucoup d'opérateurs
criminels qui ont décidé que le réseau
social c'était un élément qui permettait
de vous avez parlé il y a quelques en
première partie d'émission de la jeune
fille qui s'était fait harceler et les
harceleuses se répandent beaucoup sur
les réseaux sociaux avant pendant et
depuis donc il y a une sorte de
libération générale sur le réseau social
à la fois pour des raisons criminelles
mais pour toute une série de sujets où
il y a plus de compréhension de ce qui
est autorisé interdit après tout le
réseau social c'est une sorte de vie
parallèle mais de la vraie vie c'est pas
c'est pas de la téléréalité beaucoup de
choses sont scriptées là c'est de la
réalité télé c'est l'inverse et vous
avez parlé de la Colombie un instant
mais mais nous on se dit on croyait pas
que ça allait arriver en France et de
plus en plus c'est vrai que on voit que
il y a de plus en plus de règlement de
compte vous avez dit tout à l'heure et
il y a de plus en plus de sûr à gages et
de plus en plus jeunes pourquoi les
tueurs à gages ils prennent des tueur à
gages de plus en plus jeunes ceux qui
alors pour trois raisons la première qui
est une fausse raison c'est de penser
que la minorité sera une excuse ils se
font interpellés contrairement à une
idée répandue en matière criminelle
c'est pas vrai un mineur
ça change rien sachant on n'est pas on
n'est pas condamné à exactement la même
peine mais on peut être poursuivi
condamné interpellé arrêter c'est le
niveau de discernement qui compte alors
quand on voit la vidéo discernement on
peut discuter visiblement il avait pas
Buc de l'abattoir mais au-delà de ce
problème là il peut être poursuivi
condamné interpellé il risque 20 ans
comme tout le monde 20 ans
est-ce qu'on a reconnu lui alors il est
connu et reconnu alors quel est le
modèle de de ces tueur à gages ils
viennent alors vous allez les les
enfants de ils pensent que c'est un
processus d'intégration en fait il y a
un glissement vieillesse technicité une
forme d'expérience dans le monde du
crime vous montez les chaînes et donc
donc parfois par exemple le Mexicain
Raoul mesata a appelé M6 junior ah
d'accord mini 6 parce que son père M6
est un cador du crime au Mexique et donc
il se faisait reconnaître et il voulait
se faire un prénom donc il s'est fait un
mini prénom d'autres sont des initiés
c'est-à-dire qu'ils veulent absolument
entrer dans ce domaine être protégé donc
préserver des autres surtout des des
enfants qui sont au sol laissés à
l'abandon et qui veulent survivre
d'abord ensuite se faire un nom et donc
il trouve un parrain ou un initiateur et
qui leur montre comment devenir un bon
professionnel puis ils prennent voilà
c'est un peu comme David Carradine dans
dans kung-fu petit scarabée pouf le jour
où ils arrivent à prendre la pierre ils
vont ils veulent de leurs ailes et puis
certains ben simplement ils ont ils ont
la violence ils ont besoin d'argent ils
voient la réussite et c'est pas à
l'école qu'il pense pouvoir régler leurs
problèmes d'intégration dans la société
et donc il passe à ce niveau là et
l'augmentation du trafic de stupe la
guerre du stup c'est-à-dire la fin des
grands-parents notamment dans la des
corso Marseillais en fait à Marseille
vous avez depuis très longtemps une gare
de succession une guerre de Sécession et
donc les parrains ont été éliminés par
des gens de plus en plus jeunes qui
durent de moins en moins longtemps et
qui est pour des raisons évidentes
éliminées vous avez parlé de la
paternelle la paternelle c'est le lieu
des plus grands de la plus grande guerre
criminelle
à Marseille ces temps-ci qui provoque un
très grand nombre de règlements de
comptes y compris de règlement de compte
sur des gens qui ont eu que le malheur
de passer par là alors regardez les
témoignages dans le reportage
tout pour faire partir la nuit
c'est un territoire de guerre moi j'ai
perdu plusieurs amis vous sentiez que ça
pouvait être vous le prochain
selon eux les gangs recrutent en postant
des messages sur des applications
sur snapchat ou télégram dans des vidéos
privées combien on leur propose 3000
4000 5000 euros il y a une trentaine une
quarantaine d'années des tueurs à gages
ça pouvait taper jusqu'à 100000 euros on
est dans un climat avec des mecs qui
sont prêts à tout pour montrer que ils
sont capables de tuer des mecs et ça
franchement c'est c'est assez flippant
quoi
c'est exactement ce que vous disiez
c'est vrai que là comment
ils ont
imaginait qu'ils sont pas un contrat
toutes les semaines
si pouvait le ferait il faut quand même
qu'il y ait un client et qui ont
exactement et une cible il faut la
repérer il faut aller alors c'est de
moins en moins professionnel parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de victimes collatérales on
parle beaucoup des règlements de compte
mais il y a beaucoup de réglement de
compte sur des gens qui n'étaient le
malheur d'être là une balle perdue des
enfants parfois la mère de famille qui
s'est fait tuer il y a quelques semaines
donc on est dans un processus où on tire
plutôt à la rafale n'importe où mais
vous avez récemment eu à Paris un
règlement de compte extrêmement curieux
et mystérieux sur un jeune agent
immobilier ce processus est en train de
se répondre parce que les guerres à
Marseille se répandent toujours et à
Lyon et à Paris parce que il y a en fait
il y a pas de territoire le territoire
il a disparu et les Marseillais ont
toujours eu besoin de conquérir Paris et
la conquête de Paris c'est toujours
extrêmement compliqué il y a des fortes
résistances locales c'est des
territoires qui se qui sont en parfaite
contre en parfaite
dépendance et donc dès que ça frotte à
un moment ou un autre se mettre d'accord
ça arrive soit il se met pas d'accord et
ça se termine pas bien qui dit oui je
voulais savoir selon vous quelles sont
les causes qu'est-ce qui a basculé en
France pour qu'on en arrive à ce niveau
là c'est 5 ou 10 dernières années quel
est selon vous la cause principale de ce
truc là qu'est-ce qu'on avait pas avant
qui fait que maintenant bah ça arrive
chez nous
la décentralisation trafic de stupe
avant le crime organisé dirigé tout et
il avait besoin du calme parce que le
désordre c'est mauvais pour le business
mais à un moment le crime organise a
perdu le contrôle à Marseille en
particulier et puis depuis la mort de
Jean-Jacques Colonna qui était à la fois
le juge de paix et le parrain du crime
il n'y a pas eu de remplaçant j'ai
toujours eu une succession qui s'est
organisée au fil du temps depuis les
années 1920 1930 depuis borsalino
on a ce processus où chaque fois un
groupe en représentait un autre ça n'est
plus le cas il n'y a plus de parrain
incontesté de juge de paix et juste en
juge de paix épais qui est important
c'est à dire la moyenne de faire régner
une forme d'or de répartir les de
repartir les territoires ça s'appelle la
commission aux États-Unis il y a des
territoires ouverts des territoires
fermés mais les as-tu en connaît la même
chose quand la police américaine dans
les années 90 a commencé à détruire les
5 grandes familles qui tenaient le crime
à New York il y a eu une explosion de la
violence et du crime parce qu'il n'y
avait plus de police parallèles du crime
et puis au bout d'un moment ils sont
rendus compte que c'était pas une si
bonne idée que ça ils ont dû régler une
augmentation historique des homicides à
New York la perte de 500000 habitants
parce que les gens fuient la ville était
au bord de la rupture de la faillite et
pour se faire ils ont rétabli une sorte
d'ordre de négociation sur bon alors qui
fait quoi et à condition que vous tuez
pas les touristes vous tirez pas
n'importe où et vous acceptez une sorte
de contrôle social de ce qui est toléré
dans le crime une sorte d'exutoire et
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne en tout
cas aux États-Unis il semble qu'en
France alors à Marseille c'est toujours
été mais depuis carbone et Spirito mais
là il y a un vrai sujet j'ai un ami qui
me dit le minimum pour une grosse tête à
Marseille c'est 1929 euros il est très
précis
1929 €. il doit y avoir une raison mais
il me dit à Marseille c'est le Lidl du
tueur à gage aujourd'hui donc
ça fait sur le plan de la pardon sur le
plan de la loi qui risque la plus grande
sanction entre le tueur à gage et le
commanditaire
il y a aucune différence d'accord oui
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui en France il y a y
a un
turc non d'abord parce qu'il faudrait
les arrêter les interpeller les
identifier alors ceux qu'on les ceux
qu'on connaît alors nous on l'a pas fait
les Australiens l'ont fait les Canadiens
l'ont fait il y a quelques années et en
général c'était alors un peu plus âgé
uniquement pour des raisons financières
et pour des primes d'assurance ou des
questions d'héritage et plutôt 35 50 à
l'époque mais ça date il y a une
quinzaine d'années il y a un
rajeunissement général des opérateurs
criminels pour des tas de raisons et là
particulièrement sur cette question en
France mais aussi parce que on a créé un
espace où c'est possible par la
concentration de problèmes sur des
territoires spécifiques et une sorte de
sortie
alors je vais pas faire le coup de la
misère parce que c'est pas toujours ça
et ça n'est pas la réponse à ça mais il
y a une sorte de concentration de tous
les problèmes à un seul endroit et
surtout la déperdition du contrôle
social c'est-à-dire la chute du service
public de l'éducation comme la
difficulté qu'on les parents dans des
conditions très difficiles de gérer
leurs enfants notamment AD intéressant
et puis l'adolescence en général la
capacité à faire déni défi délits ce qui
est la règle du psychiatre qui vous
explique ce que c'est la crise
d'adolescence donc tous ceux qui ont
fond de cet âge là ce que je veux dire
il y a un problème de de ça et donc ça
crée un marché et regardez celui qui a
donné pour 50 balles qui a dit c'est lui
Samuel Paty il a pas fait pour que
Samuel soit assassiné il a fait parce
que 50 balles c'est 50 balles il sait
pas poser la question du pourquoi il y a
une question qui revient vraiment sur
les réseaux là c'est ce que Mathéo le
tueur à gage est-ce qu'il a été arrêté
lui à ma connaissance il est identifié
je sais pas j'ai pas regardé le non je
ne sais pas non plus ouais
identification mais je sais pas si elle
a été arrêté